a follow-up to a story we brought you
last night on 8 news now at 11. victoria
saha spoke to 16-year-old christian
murphy's dad phillip murphy doesn't
understand why his son was shot by a
neighbor detectives tell us the man who
shot the teen was acting in self-defense
8 news now has confirmed the boy was
shot in the back of the head it happened
april 11th in the foothills community
near flamingo and fort apache phillip
murphy says christian and his brother
were fighting outside the neighbor
somehow got involved and shots were
fired
my oldest son said that he did see
christian on the ground
with his arms spread out with his head
up
and that was the last time he seen him
and the man was standing over him i've
been grieving stressed out just
for the most part of it though is just i
want answers i want some there's no
justification of a man shooting my child
in the back of the head
eight news now did try to go to that
neighbor's house there's a reporter but
our crew was turned away police say
christian was shooting before he was
shot this investigation is ongoing there
have not been any arrests or charges to
this point the case still needs to go
through the da's office and our records
request in this case has been denied so
far by metro the